an actor isn't usually actually in
harm's way when performing horrific
scenarios for our entertainment but some
stars throw caution to the wind going
above and beyond to ensure their
performance conveys pure terror is it
worth it you decide how do you remake a
Dario Argento classic like Suspiria if
you're Dakota Johnson the star of the
remake the answer is that you commit to
an unhealthy degree as Johnson told Elle
her experience of playing the dancer
Hyup so much that I had to go to therapy
the shooting conditions were brutal the
primary location was an abandoned hotel
atop of mountain the weather was dry and
cold resulting in constant discomfort
among the cast plus due to the 30
telephone poles on the building's roof
there were supposedly electricity
pulsing through the building to the
point that everyone was shocking each
other
what's Johnson done since then she's
starting her own production company
hoping to create projects that showcase
what she wants to do which presumably
include non-electrified sets when film
critic Roger Ebert asked Shelley Duvall
what it was like working with master
director Stanley Kubrick on the shining
Duvall responded bluntly calling it
almost unbearable Kubrick's film is an
acclaimed horror classic but it arguably
came at the cost of Duvall's
sanity who called shooting it
excruciating for nine months she put in
at least 12 hours a day screaming and
crying bearing the brunt of Kubrick's
artistic impulses one Hollywood legend
goes that Kubrick asked for over 120
takes of a scene involving Duvall and a
baseball bat
get back stop swinging give me the back
and after her trials were complete and
the film was released critics wrote of
the film's genius in every way except
for Duval's performance
she told Hebert the reviews were all
about Kubrick like I wasn't there
perhaps with the star directors such as
Kubrick I said critics get mesmerised by
his name and forget the actors tobe
Hooper's exploitation classic Texas
Chainsaw Massacre is steeped in grimy
authenticity it really looks like
Marilyn Burns was stuck in a
slaughterhouse full of rotten corpses
and tortured until she screamed the
reason it looks like this is well she
was the dinner scene when she was tied
up and taunted Cooper tied her up and
set the other actors mercilessly on her
in fact an absurd number of horrible
events that her character endures
happened to the actress herself the
heroic moment when burns escapes by
jumping through the window Byrnes
actually jumped through a window
thankfully she didn't get placed on a
hook or have to fight off actual
cannibals The Exorcist is to this day
such a picture of absolute horror your
body might hurt from all the tension
carried while watching but it still
wouldn't compare to what Ellen Burstyn
went through to play Chris the poor
mother of a possessed little girl in one
scene
Chris's daughter Regan pushes her to the
floor hard after take one burst and
complained to director William Friedkin
that the stunt coordinator was pulling a
rope tied to burst and too strongly
burst and told HuffPost live and Billy
said well it has to look real and I said
I know it has to look real but I'm
telling you I could get hurt and so he
said okay don't pull her so hard
after that Friedkin called action and
Burstyn was slammed to the floor so hard
she suffered permanent spinal injuries
Burstyn suspects freaking one of the
good-looking take at all costs during
production on the 2003 horror film
Gothica Robert Downey jr. and Halle
Berry were in the middle of an intense
scene
Downey was supposed to grab Barry's arm
in a certain choreographed way but
instead he grabbed it just about as
wrong as you could grab it and it
snapped
[Music]
director matsukata vets found it to be a
lucky break
as the paws and shooting gave him a
chance to prep for upcoming action
scenes he didn't have time to plan
poltergeist is riddled with controversy
was the production really cursed
did Toby Hooper or Steven Spielberg
really directed all of these questions
may never have official answers but we
do know one thing for certain actor Jo
Beth Williams who played Diane Freeling
had a hauntingly miserable time making
the movie in a reddit asked me anything
session Williams called the shoot
physically very hard especially the
moments when she was dropped into a pool
full of a gross slimy concoction during
one particularly yucky scene Williams
shared the screen with some skeletons
she told reddit when we were shooting
I thought the skeletons were fake I
thought the prop Department made them
but later I found out they were real
skeletons bought very cheaply that
really grossed me out the supernatural
seemed to have followed Williams home
away from the film as well when she
returned to her rented apartment after a
day's shooting all of the pictures were
crooked
so she straightened them however it the
next day pictures were crooked once
again that's almost spookier than just
about anything that's actually in
poltergeist check out one of her newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]